supreme court today heard arguments in
an abortion case that has potential
implications for roe v wade it's almost
impossible to find any kind of rational
commentary about this case if you go
over to msnbc we try not to but we did
for your sake today
here's the legal analysis of the case
watch
this is exactly what a society that is
against women looks like and sadly
listen we are not too far away from
becoming gilead 2.0 it's month 5011 of
the pandemic and women are still losing
their jobs or dropping out of the
workforce by the hundreds of thousands
while men gain jobs in states like texas
are saying under his eye as they wrench
away a woman's right to an abortion
they keep using the word woman but of
course msnbc and cnn abc news nbc the
democratic party they don't believe that
there is a category such as women so
house is a threat to women
whatever it's too stupid even to
continue analyzing the question is what
really did happen today in the supreme
court abby johnson is a former planned
parenthood director who became a
pro-life advocate she's been watching
very carefully she joins us tonight abby
thank you for coming on so what happened
and what are the implications of this
well i thought the solicitor did very
well from mississippi today laying out
the case and of course we saw some
really interesting and quite honestly
idiotic comments coming from a couple of
the liberal justices on the bench today
sotomayor actually saying that in the
past 50 years we haven't seen any
advancement of medicine in maternal and
fetal medicine i mean she actually said
i don't think we've had any scientific
development so these are the same people
that want us to follow the science but
yet they're telling us there haven't
been any scientific developments made in
maternal and fetal medicine in the past
50 years
um so it's pretty interesting i mean
this case could completely
gut roe and casey so this could turn
abortion back over to the states and
allow states to
enact
their state constitutions we know that
24 states would make abortion illegal
because of trigger bans in their state
so um this could have huge implications
across our nation so but just to be
clear i mean no honest legal
analyst believes that roe is an honest
decision i mean it's grotesque but if it
were to disappear tomorrow
states would
do what we call commit democracy right
voters would get to decide what they
think of abortion that would be the
effect or am i missing something no
you're exactly right and gorsuch made
that very clear on the bench uh when he
was asking biden solicitor he said you
know i just want to make this clear
uh it's not that abortion would be gone
we're not here to say that the the the
supreme court would be banning abortion
this would go back to the states correct
right and uh and that's absolutely right
yeah well no one ever says that but it's
true
people could actually vote on something
for once abby johnson great to see you
tonight thank you hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else